we're paying a little bit of a mos to
mama you know
we can't not billy lord shared an
emotional tribute to her royal heritage
and who might you be leia
on tuesday the daughter of the late
carrie fisher celebrated may the 4th by
sharing
these sweet photos featuring her baby
son kingston
watching his grandmother in star wars a
new hope
are you short for a storm trooper huh
as you can see the tributes don't stop
there kingston is wearing a knitted cap
made to look like carrie fisher's iconic
haircut
in another pic the little padawan is
sporting a onesie with the likeness of
princess leia
you never know in september billy
shocked the world when she announced
her and fiance austin rydell were proud
parents
she had not previously shared that she
was pregnant billy captioned
this photo introducing kingston fisher
lord rydel
in december billy shared this photo of
she and carrie on the four year
anniversary of her mother's passing
writing sending my love and strength to
everyone out there that's missing a
loved one they've lost
she wants to be on tv so this is just
for us
and then i'll okay what do you want to
say sweetheart
you're on tv carrie and billy hit the
red carpet together throughout her
childhood
and billy even later joined the family
business general
are you seeing this two more x-wings
down she co-starred alongside her mother
in the final installments of the
skywalker saga i see you guys coming up
the red carpet mother and daughter i'm
thinking to myself what's your first
star wars memory and then bring it
to this moment here with your mom now
come in here the first star wars memory
for
my memory was me kicking and screaming
because she
was begging me to watch it i was like
four years old she put it on
like a beggar they did not hire me
because i was a beggar
she's a beggar and she's born to run
anyway whatever so she begged me to
watch it i obliged i sat down
i was like four sometimes people to get
me to turn around
hey princess leia like i'm gonna you
know be someone
yes help me obi-wan kenobi you're my
only hope
they were great movies to make and and
they're great to be in there the only
fairy tales i think we've currently got
if you go by joseph campbell
[Music]